Democrats impeach President Trump as
Alyssa Milano leads a rally chant that
this is what democracy looks like we
examine what happens now and we remember
what our founding fathers thought about
democracy then alleged comedian Michelle
wolf jokes about how killing her child
made her feel like God
CNN refuses to believe a CNN poll that's
favorable toward President Trump and
stick around for the mailbag to get my
thoughts on whether or not we should
boycott Star Wars about the Crusades and
about the age-old question of whether
Christians should date non-believers all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
they did it the Democrats have impeached
president Trump so what happens now at
this point I'm actually half hoping that
the Senate convicts just so that
president Pence can then institute a
full-on Handmaid's Tale style dystopian
Puritan tyranny not because anybody
wants that to happen least of all Mike
Pence but just because it would totally
own the libs can you imagine how
hilarious that would be dystopian
obviously but it would be absolutely
hilarious they'd think they'd impeach
Trump and they think because they've
never read the Constitution that that
means that now Hillary Clinton is gonna
be President and then just peeking out
from behind the curtain is Mike Pence
they're just passing out bonnets left
and right that would make it almost all
worthwhile though I say almost because
this actually is sort of a sad thing for
our republic the we've gotten into this
habit now of impeaching presidents the
impeachment power should very very
rarely be used we're now using it a lot
because we're prioritizing the Congress
and the legislature as somehow a more
important branch of government then the
executive and you've heard this a little
bit from both parties to diminish the
role of the executive but if you
diminish it too much you totally throw
our system out of whack and that's
what's happening all around the country
people are throwing our system of
government out of whack they don't even
know what our system of government
really is we don't need to cover very
much on impeachment obviously you've
you've we knew this was going to happen
we've been talking about what it will
look like all week worth pointing out
that two Democrats voted against
impeachment and no Republicans voted for
impeachment so that means that the vote
against impeachment was bipartisan and
the vote for impeachment was not it was
strictly partisan it was only Democrats
Nancy Pelosi knows that this is bad for
her it does not look good I mean it's
rallied her base over the past 24 hours
they'll probably be able to fundraise
pretty well over the next I don't know a
couple weeks or something except
actually that we're heading into
Christmas and New Year's right now so
people are tuning out of politics if
they wanted to fundraise off this
probably should have picked a better
time still
see Pelosi knows this doesn't really
help her looking into 20/20 so actually
right now she's threatening not even to
deliver the impeachment to the Senate
meaning that the house has voted to
impeach the president that's done with
but what would happen now is the house
would deliver that to the Senate the
Senate would conduct a trial and then
presumably the Senate will acquit
President Trump because the Republicans
still hold the Senate and this whole
impeachment thing is a hoax so they have
no leverage they're giving away all
their leverage and that's why Nancy
Pelosi is saying well we're gonna vote
to impeach him but maybe we won't give
it over to the Senate and you just see
cocaine Mitch they're sort of rubbing
his fingers together like yes yeah do
whatever you want Nancy because right
now that the vote has already happened
Republicans hold all of the leverage
before we move on past impeachment I do
want to give a quick shout-out to
Republican representative Bill Johnson
you know all the congressmen were making
these impassioned pleas yesterday on the
topic of impeachment but Bill Johnson
more than anyone else
gave a truly powerful oration on the
presidency on the legislature and on the
topic of impeachment here is
representative Johnson tomans recognized
for 30 seconds thank you madam Speaker
in a day heavy and verbal debate I
choose to use my time to enumerate in
detail every high crime and misdemeanor
committed by the president United States
I will do so now yeah it's still playing
he's there he's standing he's looking
around Wow see that that was this is the
best argument I've heard yet it's so
concise it's so coherent where have I
heard this you know much times expired
peel back uh-huh beautiful absolutely
beautiful they say that poets are the
unacknowledged legislators of the world
that's a quote by shelley and i can't
help but feel that that's true i can't
help but feel i played a small role in
the creation of that powerful speech and
that speech i think will go down in the
annals of American history
as as the decisive oration on the topic
of president Trump's impeachment really
really great by the way if you want to
read the book that I think gave bill
Johnson so much inspiration for that
oration I recommend you go purchase
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide and number one
international best-selling book endorsed
by President Trump meanwhile so you had
all these congressmen fighting all day
you had pretty much just one funny
speech about which was from Bill Johnson
meanwhile in LA you had a ton of left
wingers I mean congressmen
ex-congressman
that throuple derelict Katie hill flew
out and hung out with Alyssa Milano they
were holding a rally to celebrate the
impeachment and to celebrate the
attempted overthrow of the 2016
presidential election Alyssa Milano was
one of the people leading this rally
this protest and here is what she had to
say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah if that is what democracy looks
like count me out I'm gone I'm cashing
in my democracy chips get me out of here
maybe she's right though maybe she's
right
I think a lot of people see these
rallies they see this hoax impeachment
and they say that's not what democracy
is supposed to look like maybe that is
what democracy looks like we will
examine exactly what democracy looks
like and exactly what our founding
fathers thought about it but first I got
to thank our friends over at Rock Auto I
love rockauto.com first and foremost
because it's an incredibly helpful
company that gives you fair prices with
an easy to navigate website that cuts
out these bogus middlemen who markup the
prices all the time the other reason I
love it because it's a family business
all right Rock Auto is a a tightly held
family business they've been serving
Auto Parts customers online for 20 years
which in the scope of the internet is
pretty much the whole time go-to Rock
Auto comm to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
Rock Auto has everything from engine
control modules and brake parts to tail
lamps motor oil even new carpet you know
when you go to the auto parts store in
person people they don't have your part
they just go online and then they buy
and then they mark it up a whole lot so
go go right to the source I wish I had
done that when my car broke down three
months ago between here in San Francisco
rockauto.com is just so terrific I
really love these guys I love how easy
to navigate their website is
rockauto.com go there right now see all
the parts available for your car or
truck then right Knolls canna wles
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you
you're gonna love these guys they're
gonna be your go-to guys for Auto Parts
there there's nobody better rockauto.com
ad Knolls in the box where they ask
where that you heard
about them is that what democracy looks
like if it is it sends a shiver down my
spine but I think she might be right she
might be just look at impeachment there
is a legal basis for impeachment there's
supposed to be at least and yet the
House Democrats overruled these
constitutional safeguards they overruled
the law in favor of political
strong-arming they basically said we've
got the votes we're going to impeach
this is democracy who cares that you
didn't commit a high crime or
misdemeanor who cares that you didn't
commit bribery they dropped the bribery
charge who cares that you didn't commit
treason doesn't matter we're gonna
impeach you anyway cuz we got the votes
and it's gonna be strictly partisan now
a couple of Democrats with a political
conscience actually voted against
impeachment but the whole rest of the
caucus voted for impeachment and they
didn't even pretend by the way many of
them did not even pretend to have a
legal basis for this impeachment here's
a Democratic Representative Schakowsky
exemplifying that mob rule she explains
her basis of impeachment which is not
constitutional not high crimes or
misdemeanors
it's not even Ukraine which was the
ostensible basis for this version of
impeachment she said that she decided to
impeach President Trump because her
child told her to it is my adult son
ayan Schakowsky whom I will always
credit for my decision last June to
support an impeachment inquiry it had
never been my goal to impeach a
president but I in made such a
compelling case he reminded me of the
oath I have taken eleven times now to
support and defend the Constitution of
the United States he said mom this is
not about politics this is not about
party and pushing back against my
arguments he said this has nothing to do
with the final outcome it's about doing
the right thing
even if others don't he made me see that
it was about my legacy my modest place
in history
I want to thank you my son for helping
me do the right thing today to vote to
impeach the President of the United
States Donald Trump because no American
is above the law
I want to thank you my son for helping
me to realize that my job isn't to
uphold the Constitution that my job
isn't to support the norms of American
Republican government
my job is to do what my kid tells me to
do so that I get all the good fields and
that's what congressmen are for they're
for having really good fields so thank
you thank you so much my son this is
this is mob rule this is government by
sentiment this is government by sacaron
feeling rather than government by law or
government by our Constitution or even
our traditions or our norms this kind of
mob rule has affected so many areas of
our government not not even just this
one Congress this one congresswoman it's
come all over the place and what you've
got to remember is that we don't
actually have a democratic form of
government or at least we're not
supposed to everyone seems to forget
that little detail the word democracy
appears nowhere in the Declaration of
Independence the word democracy appears
nowhere in our Constitution you know
what word shows up Republic Republic
shows up through so many of our founding
documents the founders were terrified of
democracy they didn't like democracy
Democrats today would have us believe
that our government is supposed to be
some ever pure democracy but it's not at
least not as the founding fathers
envisioned it in their great wisdom the
founding fathers knew what democracy
looks like here's what James Madison
father of our Constitution here's what
he wrote in Federalist 10 quote
democracies have ever been spectacles of
turbulence and contention have ever been
found incompatible with personal
security or the rights of property and
have in general been is short in their
lives as they have been violent in their
deaths
pretty sharp fella that James Madison
our government is not a democracy for
that reason our government is a republic
and yet we've become more democratic
over time this has happened indisputably
and in some ways as the government has
become more democratic we appreciate
that extension of various rights to
people who ought to have had those
rights but in many ways the
democratization of our government
especially the federal government has
not worked out terribly well for us
Republican representative Barry looter
milk I hope I'm pronouncing that right
he made the rounds on Twitter yesterday
because he compared President Trump at
his impeachment trial to Jesus now once
we get behind the part that everyone's
laughing at we'll get to actually a very
important observation that he's made
about democracy while kids are then the
second first I got to thank our friends
over at Boleyn branch you know how much
I love Boleyn branch I got to sleep what
18 19 hours a day to keep up my my
beauty to keep up my my youthful looks
and so when I sleep I want to make sure
I'm treating myself very nicely
everything Bowl and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton which means they
start out super soft and they get even
softer over time and by buying directly
from them there's no middleman you're
essentially paying wholesale prices when
you buy luxury sheets if you go to the
department store something they can cost
a kid you not like a thousand dollars
but if you buy them through Boleyn
branch you don't need to worry about
that I am a man of simple tastes okay I
am easily satisfied by the very best
this is true when it comes to drinks and
food and when it comes to my bedding
especially when it comes to my bedding
get it
treat yourself especially it's such a
great price that you can get from Beau
and branch you're gonna love it most
people spend a third of their life on
their beds make sure you got the best
you'll you will thank me later I promise
shipping is free try them for 30 nights
if you don't love them send them back
but you're gonna love them right now to
get started get $50 off your first set
of sheets at Boleyn branch com promo
code Michael Boleyn branch comm $50 off
your first set of sheets that's promo
code Michael bol Ellen branch comm promo
code Michael mi CH AE L you will thank
me later so representative Barry looter
milk who is a Republican congressman
from Georgia
he made the rounds
yesterday his clip went viral because he
compared the impeachment of President
Trump to the trial of Jesus Christ we
can all agree I think that claims of
president Trump's divinity have been
exaggerated
however congressman looter milk makes a
very good point about the Democrats here
he makes a very good point about
democracy you take this historic vote
today one week before Christmas I want
you to keep this in mind when Jesus was
falsely accused of treason Pontius
Pilate gave Jesus the opportunity to
face his accusers during that sham trial
Pontius Pilate afforded more rights to
Jesus than the Democrats have afforded
this president in this process I yield
back okay
not a perfect analogy I suppose we can
say and generally speaking let's say
generally a Trump is not Jesus okay I
suppose you're gonna have a sort of st.
Paul scenario where he says it's no
longer I who lives but Christ who lives
in me but I could never presume
president Trump's faith so let's put
that part aside for right now Trump
isn't Jesus but the Democrats are
Pontius Pilate you know when Christ is
talking to Pontius Pilate Christ tells
Pontius Pilate that he has come to bear
witness to the truth Pontius Pilate
responds in one of the most famous
moments of the entire Bible he shrugs
his shoulders and he says what is truth
and he walks away and this isn't just
some sloppy moment from Pontius Pilate
just some throwaway line it's the
evidence that Pontius Pilate is a cynic
a cynic in the true sense of the word he
doesn't care for the truth he is totally
indifferent to what the truth is he
doesn't believe in a way that there is
objective truth that cynicism has
infected much of our society but it is
especially affected the left which now
denies objective truth as a matter of
course they'll say there's your truth
and my truth but there's no the truth
there's - who are you to say that you're
a man if if you think that you're a
woman then you can be a woman whatever
you want to be you can be Who am I to
presume you're prone
there's no objective reality so I can't
presume the truth the left has
demonstrated this especially in this
impeachment trial I mean they have been
trying to impeach Trump now since before
he took office and the reason has
changed the only thing that has stayed
consistent is that they want to impeach
him so initially it was we're gonna
impeach him because he conspired with
Russia two and a half year thirty two
million dollar investigation into that
we conclusively can say he did not
conspire with Russia okay then we're
gonna beat him because he maybe slept
with stormy Daniels 10-15 years ago no
okay that's not a crime all right we're
gonna get him because he didn't pay
taxes oh he did pay taxes all right
we're gonna get him because he conspired
with Ukraine is that one good I know
Ukraine's at war with Russia but let's
just let's go with that one now Ukraine
okay there's no evidence that he
committed any crimes with Ukraine well
whatever we're gonna get him anyway
obstruction of Congress and abuse of
power yeah that's pretty good you can't
those are so vague that you can't
possibly refute that well we're gonna
impeach him anyway that's cynicism a lot
of people are cynical in politics a lot
of politicians don't have very much
regard for the truth however this is
this especially brazen this is
especially in your face this disregard
for the truth another tough feature
about radical democracy another really
unfortunate feature is that it breaks
all constraints on society all right
it's obviously broken our constitutional
constraints this happens time and time
again it's broken our legal constraints
when when people feel that they can just
impose their will regardless of what the
framework of our country says but it
also breaks the constraints of the moral
order nowhere is this better exemplified
then in the recent special of the
alleged comedian Michelle wolf you'll
remember her she was at the White House
Correspondents Dinner a few years ago
and she made fun of Sarah Sanders and
this was something of a controversy so
Michelle Wolf's got a new special on
Netflix and she decided to do a whole
bit a whole joke about how killing her
child made her feel like God here she is
you feel like you should have this sense
of shame after you get an abortion well
you can feel any way you want
after you get an abortion get one
see how you feel you know my abortion
made me feel very powerful you know
people say you can't play God
[Music]
[Applause]
morgan freeman god
you know that's pretty ghastly I think
it's pretty repugnant most people are so
shocked by that joke because it's so
real it's so true it's actually why it's
a it's a pretty good joke if not for all
the suffering if not for all the dead
babies if not for the reality of it
because she actually killed her child it
would be a very funny joke if not for
the victims why would it be a funny joke
because it's so true
she's right I'm sure she did feel very
powerful the ability to snuff out
innocent life makes one feel powerful it
makes one take on the presumed to have
the authority of God yeah that she's
right that's not a good thing that's a
very bad thing the impulse of radical
egalitarian democracy is to make each
man a god that's the trouble and what is
the result of that is the result of that
a good thriving wonderful society where
we all love each other and we're all
very nice to each other no the result of
that is a society that is coarse and
capricious and miserable and murderous
that's what happens does any of us want
that the framers did not want that the
current Democratic Party does I mean you
saw this even in the decision of Justice
Kennedy and Planned Parenthood v Casey
where he famously said in the early 90s
that we each have the right to define
our own reality are on our own objective
reality will have to subdue itself to
our own subjective whims each of us will
be gods in this kind of radical
democracy that is a pretty new idea and
that is a consequence of saying that
we're all absolutely equalist we will
presume equality even with God which is
absurd and has pretty disastrous
consequences both on the individual and
on society now blending the two blending
the cultural realm and the political
realm realm we see the near effects of
this radical democracy now in the most
cringe inducing video from Elizabeth
Warren in the past 24 hours it seems
like every
three or four days you get a really
cringe inducing video from her we'll get
to that in a second first christmas is
coming up guys
christmas the holiday season New Year's
Eve especially people want to go out get
a little bit less have a couple adult
beverages one or two Coca Cola's stay
off the road because even if you're not
just drinking even if maybe you want to
puff on that Haitian oregano something
like that stay off the road I know you
think that one is okay to smoke
marijuana is okay and then you get in a
car but driving drunk is not okay we all
know that the risks of drunk driving you
get in a car crash people get hurt or
killed almost 29 people in the US die
every single day in alcohol impaired
vehicle crashes what's that equal one
person every 50 minutes but even though
drunk driving fatalities have fallen by
1/3 in the past three decades drunk
driving crashes still claim more than
ten thousand lives each year and many
people don't realize driving while high
can be just as dangerous in 2015
42% of drivers killed in crashes tested
positive for drugs
all right from 2007 to 2015 marijuana
use among drivers killed in crashes
doubled driving while high is deadly so
don't kid yourself if you're impaired
from alcohol or drugs do not get behind
the wheel you can call a rideshare it
takes two seconds cost you less than 10
bucks but usually don't do it okay if
you feel different you drive different
drive high get a DUI drive sober or get
pulled over a little Christmas PSA as we
get ready for the holiday season
when you want to blend the effects when
you want to see the blend of effects of
radical democracy and culture and
politics look no further than Elizabeth
Warren lye awasa herself okay
in anticipation of tonight's democratic
debate Elizabeth Warren appeared in
another super awkward video with the
queer I star Jonathan Van Ness this was
it posted on social media and the two of
them giveaway the game on this radical
egalitarian democracy call her little
hear me do that a lot of him
you don't get started back time
Elizabeth on this episode of dnews for
yes and tomorrow is a big day
oh it is the debates the debrief end
what do you want people to take away
from it so they can go to Elizabeth
Warren common follow the debates live
and the also engage in water
conversation around a bit because this
is about making democracy work not just
for the rich folks it's about making
democracy if this is what democracy
looks like I am cashing in my chips okay
could you imagine the founding fathers
there writing the Constitution they're
writing the Federalist Papers these are
some of the most brilliant men that have
ever graced to this continent they're
contemplating how to balance perfectly
our federal government and all the
powers there that we know that men are
not governed by angels we know that men
are not angels and so we need this
government to be rightly balanced to get
our individual rights and our community
rights and our state rights and the
federal government has some power and
wow we have this great great blend I
don't think that they were dancing
around on Instagram
I don't think President Washington was
saying oh call me Georgie please no he
wasn't there was a certain formality you
you see the the problem at the very top
of this video when Elizabeth Warren says
I insist call me Liz don't call me
senator call me Liz come on I'm just
your Chum I'm just your pal we need to
make democracy work for everybody not
just the super-rich what does that mean
first of all we're not a democracy we're
a republic we're supposed to be a
republic what does that mean make it
work for everybody you mean steal their
property that's all you mean the
founding fathers knew this would happen
we've all known this would happen if you
have government by mob rule guess what
guess what will happen you'll see those
620 billionaire's some on six hundred
twenty some odd billionaires in the US
and we're just going to take their money
and that's that's no longer merely
theoretical Elizabeth Warren is
promising to do that not just to take
their income but to go in and take the
actual wealth that they've stored up
more or less going kick down their door
and take their property away all in the
name of democracy which is not supposed
to be our form of government is this
what democracy looks like I think it
very well might be you know even even
take this to CNN it's a clip that I
actually like but it shows you the same
kind of pernicious effects CNN conducted
a poll on impeachment and it turns out
that the people the the majority of the
people polled do not want to remove
President Trump from office now it
depends which poll you're looking at but
that's those are the polls we've seen so
CNN drills down CNN looks at but just
the Democrat opinion on impeachment and
they found out that during the
impeachment process had dropped from 90%
support of impeachment and removal down
to 77 percent so they've mentioned this
on CNN and a CNN contributor refuses to
believe the poll here is by party
Allison you're right you see a decline
from our last poll in Democratic support
from 90 percent down to 77 percent you
see independence holding roughly steady
they're in a slight decline among
Republicans I would just note that that
November poll was taken right on the
heels of that House Intelligence
Committee hearings I don't believe that
poll for one sec what part to heaven 92
77 % I you know it's just I don't
believe it was like it makes no sense
that that number would change like it's
a subset it's a subset of the poll and
the margin of error when you look at
just Democrats is like 6.7% in here it's
not a wild swing it's just where the
movement is in the poll I don't know
what's not to believe that's what you
know you call people up on the telephone
you get their information you pump out a
survey this is what those that we hold I
get it but I mean you know life mean in
life has Patronus that polls are
sometimes wrong and David that poll is
wrong kind of like this is just brazen I
don't care what reality says because
even I should be clear about this poll
CNN I don't believe the CNN poll found
that the majority of Americans oppose
impeachment and removal we've seen some
polls like that and so people are just
picking and choosing the polls that they
like but to see
and poll does show that Democrats are
moving in the direction of opposing
impeachment or removal during this
process and the CNN contributor says no
I'm just going to choose not to believe
that why because I said so
it's a funny example but it shows you
the impulse of radical democracy which
is cynicism which is to disregard the
truth to disregard reality to elevate
ourselves to presume that we have the
right to dictate reality to everybody
else you're seeing it happen on the
political front seeing it happen in
Congress you're seeing it happen on the
presidential campaign trail you're
seeing happen in the culture well
comedians are cackling and making jokes
about killing their own children and the
audience is huffing and hooing and
laughing and cheering that is the
conclusion of radical democracy maybe
the founders were right maybe the
founders had a point just my modest
suggestion we have got the mailbag to
get to some great stuff but first I'm
gonna save you some time and money this
Christmas season the perfect gift for
your loved ones you know what it is
after reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide that's the stocking
stuffer the main gift is the daily wire
gift membership from now till January
1st all insider plus gift memberships
will be 25% off that means your loved
one will get all the fantastic perks
plus the lovely and majestic leftist
tears tumblr you will get the savings
that's that's my favorite part of it go
to daily wire.com slash gift to get your
25% off that's daily wire.com slash gift
to get your 25% off 25% off all insider
plus gift memberships this Christmas's
and give them a gift they will thank you
for all year long daily wire com we'll
be right back with the mailbag
alright I'm gonna be running out and
catching a flight because surprise
surprise I'm gonna be heading to TP
USA's student action summit over in Palm
Beach just this evening I'm gonna fly
out I'm gonna be speaking with Andy no
tomorrow on leftist violence as you know
I was the target of leftist violence
when at Missouri University of Missouri
Kansas City some masked and Tifa weirdo
came in and sprayed me with a bunch of
creepy goop and that was fine I had to
get a new blazer but life goes on and
Ino had all sorts of awful things thrown
at him he was being punched he was
really really violently attacked by an
Tifa so we're gonna be taking that on in
Palm Beach at the student action summit
that will be tomorrow afternoons so
Friday afternoon Eastern Time early
afternoon if you happen to be in the
area come on by and say hello before
then let's answer all of your burning
questions in the mailbag from Grant
Michael my ex-girlfriend and I of five
years broke up in early November we're
still talking daily and see each other
once a week and she says we should grow
together before we get back together
she's unsure about having kids and she's
unsure about my Christian religion we're
both 25 years old do you think it is
worth pursuing the relationship still or
better to let her go she is my best
friend as well as the woman I want to
spend my life with would love some
advice PS thank you for all you do
haven't missed an episode in two years
well thank you very much grant since
you're a regular listener to the show
then and I really appreciate you
sticking around for two years I'm going
to give you some tough love drop her
like a hot potato I know you you really
love her you want to spend the rest of
your life with her she's your best
friend there's your first problem I I
could not possibly love a human being
more than I love sweet little ELISA
she's not my best friend because
friendship is a different thing than
them romantic and marital love they're
just they should be different categories
but we in our modern culture have
confused all of this and we think that
sex is basically at the bottom of all
human relationships
that isn't true you should have strong
friendships outside of your romantic
relationship or your marital
relationship or whatever that's the
first problem and I think that might be
confusing you a little bit here second
you're not yeah I mean you're young
you're very young 25 but you're not 15
or 16 so if these views are starting to
harden she doesn't like Christianity she
doesn't to have kids especially that's
not a good place to be at especially if
you've had five years together already
it's not like you're just getting
through the first six months of your
relationship and then there's this issue
of she seems to be stringing you along
so you break up but you really love her
you want to spend your life with her
she's the one who's pulling back let her
go let her go are you kidding me you're
not you got to be a man I mean I'm gonna
give you the advice that that Don
Corleone he gives to Johnny Fontaine and
the Godfather when Johnny Fontaine is
complaining about how he doesn't know
how to get out of his contract
Don Corleone he shakes him he goes
you're gonna act like a man what's the
matter with you you gotta act like a man
I mean that frankly if you want any hope
of coming back to you you've got a man
up here and just say nope you don't want
to do this that's fine I'm gonna go see
some other people and that's just the
way that it's gonna go there's a chance
you end up together I suppose but you're
not going to end up together if you if
you continue down this path of saying
you're my best friend please let's see
each other as much as we can please
let's get back together I'm not saying
that you shouldn't pursue her but if
you're gonna pursue her you gotta draw
some lines here okay you're not you
can't just let her lead the way and
dictate all the rules of the game you
got to put some boundaries on that and
make it clear that you want to date her
again and you're not going to accept
being the best friend who hangs around
and sees her once a week whenever she's
willing to spare you the time of day
that is ridiculous there's a good book
on this by Ovid called the cure for love
Romania Amore's it's a little a little
on the pagan side so you know take it
with a grain of salt when you approach
it from your faithful Christian position
but it's a very good book on the cure
for love and I think it'll give you some
good ideas in getting over this and
playing the field a little bit and then
if it's meant to be
it's meant to be and she'll come running
back and I hope that works out for you
but if not maybe you'll have a better
life with another lady from Chris after
Matt Fred posted his daily wire article
on porn people lost their minds and went
full bore to the the tyrannical
government is going to take away my
rights I couldn't help but notice that
the arguments ultimately redounded to my
body my choice don't put your religion
on me and think of the financial
situation of the woman meaning the
performer not the woman getting an
abortion but the woman who's in the porn
video what is the deal here is porn to
become the sacrament of libertarians and
some conservatives what is it going to
take for people to realize the leftist
undertones to these arguments yes that
is starting to happen and it's because
of a misunderstanding of Liberty just
like we have a misunderstanding of
democracy in our country from the very
beginning we have adopted certain
democratic principles which is a good
thing that that's wonderful but we're
not a pure democracy in the same way
from the very beginning of our country
more importantly we have preserved
Liberty but we haven't we haven't
exalted licentiousness that wasn't the
point
we haven't exalted sort of anarchistic
Liberty to do whatever we pleased in any
given time that was never the the idea
of the founding fathers that was never
the idea of this country what we
preserved it was ordered Liberty and as
Madison spells out importantly in
Federalist 51 the end of government is
justice and Edmund Burke describes
justice as ordered Liberty a Liberty
that is far higher far more exalted than
just being able to shoot up heroin in
the street whenever you want like that's
some kind of Liberty it's just a
misunderstanding of it and when you see
that threat all of our history we've had
obscenity laws we've had certain laws
about drugs and alcohol
we still have all of those laws you
realize that this kind of radical
libertarian idea that we ought to be
able to access any kind of creepy porn
of any given time and do whatever we
want to ourselves and to our brains
because as many have pointed out the the
scientific evidence is pretty clear that
high-speed video internet pornography is
wreaking havoc on our brains
specifically on the brains of young men
when you realize that when you realize
that society is about more
just this narrow licentiousness then you
can see we like to have democratic
principles we like to have Liberty but
we don't need radical totally perverted
views of either of those things from
Nathan hey Michael speaker of
Millennials and Lord of the hair do you
think that when President Trump is
reelected that he will win the popular
vote as well thanks came for Ben stayed
for Michael I think it very likely could
happen you know george w bush lost the
popular vote in 2000 and he won the
popular vote in 2004 president Trump
lost the popular vote in 2016
it would appear he's picked up a lot of
support since then I mean you can just
look at the numbers in the among black
voters or among Hispanic voters those
those numbers have increased pretty
dramatically and this is according to
multiple polls now listen the only poll
that matters is on election day but
we're not just talking about one outlier
poll here anymore we're talking about
multiple polls that shows Trump's black
support could have doubled or even even
tripled or in some cases even more that
is a pretty good sign that the president
Trump could see history repeat itself
and that he could win the popular vote
in 2020 from Sam any time a debate
starts about religion versus another
religion historically Islam versus
Christianity Christians are always hit
with B but what about the Crusades and
the Spanish Inquisition what is the best
way to respond to these Thanks
there's a lot of history that you should
read on them but the kind of 30,000 foot
view is that the Crusades were a
defensive war to stop the the Muslim
persecution of Christians in the Holy
Land in the Holy Land to which the
Muslim conquerors had no historical or
religious right in the first place they
you know sort of made sense for them to
be around Mecca but it didn't make sense
for them to conquer Jerusalem to conquer
the Holy Land and then when it comes to
the Inquisition let's not forget there
were several different inquisitions
there was the Cather Inquisition the
Middle Ages there was in the eleventh
twelfth century that was to to weed out
the Alba Jensi and heresy which would
have absolutely destroyed civilization
it was encouraging people not to get me
it was encouraging people to hate
material.we there would not be such a
thing as the West today if the Cather's
had been allowed to to take over the
culture and so there was that
Inquisition and then the Spanish
Inquisition was to find out if people
who were pretending to be Christian
actually were Christian and to root out
heretics as well which has a long
history and Christian tradition and
Thomas Aquinas defended it pretty well I
am NOT defending the Spanish Inquisition
Lanson I want to be perfectly clear
about this for when Media Matters puts
their next video out on me what I am
saying though is that the Spanish
Inquisition was a much more complicated
event than then some people would say
and the people who throw it around as
though this negates the whole of
Christendom and is somehow negates all
of Christianity or just don't know very
much about it another thing to point out
here is that the Spanish Inquisition was
led by the crown it was led by Spain not
by the church and when it comes I highly
recommend you you've read up on the
Crusades because so often I hear the
rhetoric that we have to go into Libya
you know because of a humanitarian
crisis we have to go into Syria because
of a humanitarian crisis we have to go
into any other country around the world
because of a humanitarian crisis that's
the argument for the Crusades the
argument for the Crusades is that there
was a humanitarian crisis and the Muslim
invaders were persecuting Christians
this it's the same exact argument now
there were many Crusades some better
than others so as in all things I just
think the real history is much more
interesting than the sort of ideological
revisionist slogan view of things and
it's best to approach these historical
questions with some humility and with an
air of curiosity rather than sitting up
on your high horse standing on the
shoulders of giants and thinking that
you're flying because you're not from
miles I subscribed just to ask this
question I hope I have a good answer do
you have a list you can say of books to
relearn American history as well as
history in general now that I have kids
I want to reestablish my American roots
and do away with what little I remember
of my public school education of America
but I find it daunting
once they start looking for a non
revisionist history book sure I actually
I don't think you need to go for the
most intense conservative sources and
you should only read books written by
conservative political commentators or
something but there are plenty of
popular historical books even of the
last twenty or thirty years that are not
a revisionist history for instance the
books by Nathaniel Philbrick Nathaniel
Philbrick wrote the Mayflower I don't
think that's a revisionist history book
I think it'll give you a pretty good
overview of the pilgrims and I don't
know what his politics are but that's
probably a good thing and an historian
same thing with David McCullough his
books are really terrific very popular
they're pretty easy read very
interesting he's that he's a good good
writer Ron chernow wrote up some great
biographies Hamilton which is what the
the musical is based on Washington a
number of others and if you want a good
history of the West really good
intellectual history of all of the west
from the modern era you know 1500 to the
present you know the Protestant
revolution basically through the the
late 20th century I highly recommend
dawn to decadence by Jacques Barzun he
was I think approaching a hundred when
he wrote the book so he lived through a
fifth of it and again it's really good I
don't know exactly what his politics
were but it's a great history and from
Joshua Michael do you think we will ever
again have a presidential candidate run
on balancing a budget and actually win
if so can they win while being honest
that there needs to be some entitlement
program reforms to accomplish a balanced
budget no not yet I guess in the distant
future who knows we can't predict the
future I actually have a little bit of
insight into this because I've worked on
some presidential campaigns that were
trying to put entitlement reform at the
top of the ticket and even I love mitch
Daniels who's now the president of
Purdue and he had this idea of a social
truce not a social surrender but a
social truce we're gonna pause talking
about social issues to get our fiscal
house in order to then be able to attack
all the cultural issues again and
there's no appetite for it Paul Ryan
tried to pass the path to prosperity an
entitlement reform plan this didn't work
it didn't happen why what what did we
see proven wrong by that approach which
a lot of us embraced what we saw was
that the culture
to come first I mean in many ways it's
the andrew breitbart model you cannot
deal first with the economic question
because the economics is just been
counting the economics is just a
question for calculators and economists
like Edmund Burke would say you first
have to move the culture and questions
like immigration questions like our view
on life questions like our view on
marriage questions like our view on who
gets to decide questions about life in
marriage that is going to come before we
can get to the economic question I
remember once an Coulter came when I was
in college to give a talk and she was
speaking to us and she knew that there
were a lot of pro-abortion young
conservatives that's just the way
college kids are at least at that time
and so she said look if you're debating
between voting for two candidates one of
whom is pro-life one of whom is
pro-abortion they both promised to cut
your taxes and all you care about is low
taxes vote for the pro-life politician
he will cut your taxes more what did she
mean by that she meant that the pro-life
politician will have a coherent
worldview
he will have an understanding of our
right to life and our right to property
and he will have a philosophy that's
consistent whereas the pro-abortion tax
cutting politician does not have a
consistent ideology and so he's more
likely to to lose his stomach and to
lose his spine once we get past those
cultural questions then we can get to
those economic questions it's a little
bit of an inversion of the common common
conventional view but but it's right
from Nick last question do we think that
as conservatives we should unite and
boycott the new Star Wars movie is it
our moral obligation to deprive the
studio's of money after the last Jedi
was the most Marxist anti capitalists
third wave feminism infested piece of
blasphemous propaganda garbage ever put
to screen thanks for your wisdom and yes
jingle all the way is the best Christmas
movie of all time
I don't think we need to push for a
boycott of the new Star Wars movie I
think that there will naturally be a
sort of boycott of the new Star Wars
movie because it's getting terrible
reviews and all of the recent Star Wars
movie
since Return of the Jedi with the
possible exception of rogue one which
was fine have been absolutely terrible
so I plan on boycotting the movie not
because of the politics but because it's
a terrible movie because the the other
ones have been terrible and I bet this
one will be too and I don't think that
those two questions are unrelated I
think them shoehorning and all these
stupid woke leftist politics have really
really damaged the movies but also the
fact that they've lost the sense of good
and evil they've lost the sense of
simple storytelling they've lost what
made the first Star Wars a good movie
and what made Empire Strikes Back a
pretty good movie and even what made
Return of the Jedi with all of those
little teddy bears dancing around even
that was was a fine movie and then
they've lost that sense and they've lost
that worldview and that comes out in
their politics but it also comes out in
their crappy movies that is our show I'm
going to be in Palm Beach at TP USA
tomorrow so be sure to come over and say
hello if you're there otherwise we'll
have another show before Christmas on
Monday have a good weekend in the
meantime on Michael Noel's this is the
Michael Noel's show see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producer
Mathis clever and Robert Stirling our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
assistant director hovel we douse key
editor and associate producer
Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin Fenderson
hair and makeup Jessa WA alvera
production assistant McKenna
waters the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright day Lee
Weyer 2019 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there